[موسيقى]
اخبار زلزال المغرب بايجاز من اقليم الحوز
اهلا بكم نحو 20500 قتيل في زلزال الحوز
بالمغرب فرق الانقاذ تواصل جهودها للبحث
النجين وناطق الرسمي باسم الحكومه يقول
للجزيره ان التحديات الابرز تتمثل في
صعوبه ايصال المعدات الى المناطق المنكوبه
جراء الانهيارات الصخريه
نحو 70 دوله تعرض تقديم الدعم للمغرب
مجموعات عربيه ودوليه تصل للمساعده في
عمليات الانقاذ منها قطر واسبانيا
وبريطانيا والامم المتحده تعلن وصول طريق
دولي لتقييم الاحتياجات
[موسيقى]
على صعيد التعليم وزاره التعليم المغربيه
تعلن تعليق الدراسه في المدن والمناطق
الاكثر تضررا جراء الزلزال وتكشف تضرر
خمسمائه وثلاثين مؤسسه تعليميه
وخمسين مدرسه داخليه